if you made a promise to your father and
you know all right I'll be like Dad
sorry some people if someone sit to them
punch your father in the face of 50
million W there are millions of people
in the Western World these degenerate
individuals who would go and do
that brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £1 is used to buy food
or breaks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing de that you want to do but we
turn it into a money-making machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of true s i
myself will be donating for that inshah
click the link below and donate may
Allah bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends if your father or your mother
told you that you cannot do a certain
thing and that thing that you are going
to do could potentially make you £50
million would you listen to them well
let's see what khabib did and let's see
how he learned that where did he learn
that from from Islam brother and sisters
this is where he learned from Islam he
said no to 50 million which was some
information that was leaked from some
people in the UFC he was asked to come
back for £50 million and he said no
let's hear why here's some of the videos
uh that we're going to
uh this is the video of some people in
the UFC talking about it let's watch it
for ourself let me ask you this question
I can't say a whole lot but I just got
this confirmation today he was offered
50 million to come back and he said no
because the promise he makes is there
not between me and you and everybody
else watching if you made a promise to
your father and you know all right be
like Dad
sorry like you understand give me those
FM give them to me bro that's
confirmation he passed up on 50 million
but is it because he doesn't want to
fight without his dad there or because
of promise that he would never fight
without his dad at the end of the day I
don't give a if somebody off me 50
million I don't give a what I told
my dead and you could be in heaven like
that I'm sorry I love you you know what
I'm saying I'm going to go buy you a
brand new golden headstone so there guys
you saw that SM so look I don't want to
really talk of these individuals but the
Western world is is you can see this
just they're just sing degeneracy and
immorality you know alhamdulillah Islam
shows you moral guidelines Subhan Allah
so much so that these individuals sadly
and a lot of people in the Western World
think that money is happiness like car
the comedian said I wish I could
everyone could be rich and realize that
it's not what they think that it's
miserable true happiness and cont comes
from Allah subh it comes from God
almighty this why khabib is so humble
this why you can see that he in he's
understood the Islam's essence you have
a lot of brothers who come and talk
about Islam like a parot like a parrot
yeah they look like the part you know
like sh Etc
F so many Islamic
terminologies they have not understood a
little essence of Islam people who have
in in in truly internalize the essence
of Islam you can see from the character
from their parents to the way they deal
to their humbleness you know how they
are now subh if you go to im's
book many many places brothers and
sisters Subhan Allah we are told the
importance of obeying the parents so
much so if you read the book it tells
you that you should not call your father
by his name you should not walk in front
of him you should not sit down before he
sits down and there's so many other
things that you can learn Subhan Allah
so Abu Bakr reported that the messenger
of Allah peace be upon him said Grant in
peace and said shall I tell you which is
the worst of the major worst major wrong
actions he said yes M of Allah then he
replied he said associating something
else with Allah and disobeying your
parents so much Abdullah Omar he saw
once his Subhan Allah a man from Yemen
carrying his mother on his shoulders or
in his hand yes cuz she was not able to
do she was old and he was going around
the TA he was doing ta once he finished
the TA he came to abdah Omar and asked
him he said did I pay my mom back for
what for what she's done for me and
abdah Omar said something really
profound he said said did you not pay
her back for one of she said when she
gave birth to you so there are many many
actions subh Allah when the man who came
to do offensive Jihad yes and he came he
said I left my mother and father crying
to come to join in Jad and the prophet
said return back to your mother and
father and make them happy the way you
made them cry Subhan Allah and there are
narrations over narration subh Allah
even the Quran tells you after telling
you not to worship other Idols but you
do not even you do not disobey your
parents Subhan Allah so the message is
what 50 million some people will sell
their parents some people if someone
said to them punch your father in the
face of £50 million W there are millions
of people in the western world is
degenerate individuals who would go and
do that the biggest sin the prophet P
said may his face be rubbed in dust may
his face be robbed in dust may his face
be robbed in dust that your parents
reach old age and you do not look after
them look at the pandemic of these
Western World who are leaving their
family members her parents the parents
that looked after in my country they say
two parents will look after 10 kids 10
kids will not look after two two parents
Subhan Allah two parents imagine that
they are leaving them in Care Homes to
die alone can you imagine these people
go back to to being a child they lose
their teeth they become more emotional
they forget things and you Chuck them in
Care Homes because you're too busy going
on holiday this is why I see the Western
world is dying for sh they are dying for
Islam how could you do this to your
parents how dare you to us one of the
greatest Honors that you can do is give
the honor you give to your parents look
at khabib and how he was this is why
he's a man that's respected unless that
filthy dirt bag Mayweather the scum dirt
bag yes who would sell out for
everything and anything you're a
worthless Shameless man who suppo Israel
may Allah destroy you in this life and
herea I mean or guide you so that's all
I want to say brother sisters I found it
so profound Subhan Allah for us to see
someone rejecting 50 million because of
a word that he gave and a word that a
Muslim gives is also a a contract that
you make a word that you give is very
very high in D in Islam I just want to
say brother and sisters may Allah
subhana tala bless you guys guys and
honor your parents believe me they are
your DS to J inshah and one thing that I
will finish off which is so profound
Subhan Allah is the following Hadith and
this ISD this is from abdah Omar this is
narrated by in abdah Omar said the
pleasure of the Lord lies in the
pleasure of the parent and the anger of
the Lord lies in the anger of the parent
if you want any blessing in your life W
get the duas of your mother and father
if you don't let me tell you something
even if they are wrong evil ex let's it
no problem but you should not be
treatment towards them even if they
harsh towards you you can protect
yourself no problem but do not be ill
towards them W if you please your
parents the duas that they make let me
tell you something Allah will open all
kinds of doors it's a witness for me
it's a I'm witness may Allah bless you
guys sisters till next time